اهلا بكم مشاهدينا نكمل معكم هذه التغطيه
لاحداث السودان وابدا بالعناوين
احنا جحور
الرئيس الامريكي يهدد طرفي الصراع في
السودان بعقوبات قاسيه وسي اي اي يلمح الى
صراع طويل الامد
ميدانيا لا هدنه في الخرطوم اشتباكات
عنيفه بمحيط القصر الرئاسي والقياده
العامه للجيش
وفي اخبارنا ايضا
الخارجيه الفرنسيه تؤكد للعربيه ان
الابقاء على قنوات التواصل مع روسيا امر
مهم ولا غنى
الصين محذره الغرب توسيع الناتو في اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ سيقضي على السلام الاقليمي
[موسيقى]
اصدر الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن قرارا
بتوسيع سلطات امريكا للرد على العنف في
السودان بما يشمل فرض عقوبات على
المسؤولين عن تهديد السلام وتقويض
الانتقال الديمقراطي والعنف ضد المدنيين
وانتهاك حقوق الانسان في السودان وعرب
بايدن عن التزام الولايات المتحده بدعم
تطلعات الشعب السوداني في مستقبل يسوده
السلام وتلبيه المطالب الانسانيه في
السودان عندما تسمح الظروف مؤكدا على
ضروره انهاء النزاع فورا لان الشعب
السوداني متمسك بالديمقراطيه ويرفض الصراع
على السلطه على حد وصفه واضاف رئيس
الامريكي ان العنف الجاري في السودان
ماساه وخيانه لمطالب الشعب وانه ينضم الى
دعوات الشعب السوداني لوقف اطلاق النار
بشكل دائم
قالت مديره المخابرات الوطنيه الامريكيه
بان الصراع بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع سيطول على الارجح واضافت في
احاطه امام لجنه القوات المسلحه بمجلس
الشيوخ ان طرفي النزاع في السودان يعتقدان
بانهما قادران على تحقيق الانتصار عسكريا
وانه لا توجد حوافز
تذكر للجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات حتى الان
وحذرت ايضا من ان اي دعم خارجي لطرفي
النزاع في السودان سيوفاقم الازمه ويزيد
من احتمالات انتشار تحديات الامنيه في
المنطقه
بحسب تحليلنا من المرجح ان يستمر القتال
في السودان بين القوات المسلحه وقوات
الدعم السريع حيث يعتقد الطرفان انهما
قادران على الانتصار عسكريا ولديهما
القليل من الحوافز للجلوس الى طاوله
المفاوضات كلا الجانبين يبحثان عن مصادر
خارجيه للدعم والتي اذا نجح في تحقيق ذلك
فمن المرجح ان يؤدي هذا الامر الى تفاقم
الصراعي وخلق امكانيه اكبر لتحديات غير
مباشره
ميدانيا لا جديد في السودان الصراع
العسكريه يدخل يومه العشرين الاشتباكات
تجددت وهذه المره عنيفه جدا تشبه الايام
الاولى من الصراع الجيش تمكن من السيطره
على منطقه كوبر وسلاح الاشاره في الخرطوم
بحري كما تقوم قوات الجيش بتمشيط منطقه
كوبر بعد السيطره عليها وفقا لما افاد به
مراسل العربيه هذا واظهر تصوير استهدفا
جويا لتمركزات الدعم السريع في محيط القصر
الجمهوري والقياده العامه في الخرطوم فيما
رده الاخيره بالمضادات الارضيه اما
الاوضاع الانسانيه والطبيه فهي في تفاقم
مستمر معظم المرافق الطبيه على راسها
المشافي خارج الخدمه خصوصا تلك التي في
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذا ولم تتوقف الاتهامات المتبادله بخرق
الهدنه بين الجيش والدعم السريع وفي اخرها
اتهم بيان الدعم السريع قوات الجيش بشن
قصف عشوائيه على عدد من مواقع تمركز
قواتها وبعض الاحياء السكنيه رغم الهدنه
الجديده التي بدا سريانها اليوم بيان
الدعم السريع اكد ان القصف الذي شنه الجيش
بالمدافع والطائرات يشكل تجاوزا للاعراف
والقوانين الدوليه في المقابل اكد الجيش
ان قوات الدعم السريع حاولت الهجوم على
قياده منطقه بحر العسكريه واضاف الجيش
السوداني ان قواته دمرت عددا من العربات
القتاليه التابعه للدعم السريع واستلمت
خمسه عربات تم تركها في ميدان المعركه
في دارفور حذر والي ولايه الشمال من وقوع
كارثه انسانيه بمخيمات النازحين بعدما
قامت المنظمات الامميه العامله في المجال
الانساني باجلاء موظفيها بسبب تدهور الوضع
الامني وقال ان الوضع الانساني بالولايه
ينذر بكارثه حقيقيه قبل ان يعرب عن قلق
حكومته تجاه التطورات الحاصله
هذا ويعيش العاملون في محطات توليد
الكهرباء في جنوب دارفور مدينه نيالا
اوضاعا صعبه مع استمرار المواجهات
احنا زياره بناء على المبادره واخواننا في
الكهرباء واخواننا الاتراك واخواننا
السائق اللي بيحملوا حقيقه الوقود من
بورسودان لنيال يعني
احنا في مسقعه انه كيف يفتح الطريق عشان
كل الناس
الكميه من الشكاوى يعني تعرضوا يمكن
مثل هذا المشاكل اكيد يعني كل نصيبه من
الشيل حصل له يعني ولذلك يحتسبوا لله لكن
خلاص الناس قادرين نلاقيفهم معاهم لحد ما
يرجع باذن الله سبحانه وتعالى فاني اظن في
الله كبير ونعمل السودان كلها يعني باذن
الله سبحانه
حتى الناس كلهم توقف صوت الصلاه وتحتك
لصوت الاكل السودان محتاج الان للحظه
السودان محتاج لسويد يعني تعرضنا لحاله
والله بتجي صعبه صعبه بكل صعوبه يعني ست
ايام مرت علينا قبل كذا ما حصلت علينا سته
ايام نهب ودق وسلب وبفضل الاله وبحمد الله
ومن بعده لاخواننا في الدعم السريع والله
هم يعني انقذونا ادعمونا ماديا ومع نبيا
كشف رئيس لجنه السياسات في حزب الامه
القوميه السودانيه امام الحلو للعربيه ان
حزب الامه طرح مبادره لتشكيل لجنه مشتركه
بين طرفي النزاع لتحديد اليه وقف الحال
مؤكدا ان الحزب يعمل على توحيد موقف القوى
السياسيه لوقف اطلاق النار
من
النزاع
وطرف ثالث من الشخصيات القوميه للبحث في
وقف القتال وكيفيه
اليات تنفيذ هذا الوقف نحن الان في عجلون
ونعمل على ذلك كل القوه السياسيه والمدنيه
الان نعمل على توحيده في موقف واحد محدد
في وقت هذا الصباع والان يعني اطروحات
كثيره مبادرات ان شاء الله انها تتجمع في
السرعه اللازمه
رئيس لجنه السياسات بحسب الاموال القوميه
السوداني اكد للعربيه على فشل الهدن
المتكرره في السودان في تحقيق الوقف اطلاق
النار مطالبا المجتمع الدولي بوقف الهدن
المؤقته بسبب نتائجها العكسيه على حد وصفه
السابعه
والفاشله وانا اعتقد انه هذا يعني اجابه
نتائج عكسيه موضوع الاذن اصبح فيها القتل
اكثر
ويعني يبقى اذا لا فايده من هذه
الطريقه في وقف القتال
وانا ارجو ان من المجتمع الدولي والدول
الوقفه هذه العمليه
بما يسمى بالهدنه المؤقته لم تاتي سبعه
وفشلت بل بالعكس القتل فيها والصدام في
فتره
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا مشاهدينا الصحافه
عمار ابو شيبه عمار كيف هي صوره من هناك
هل من اشتباكات يعني اصوات الرصاص كل هذا
معك تفضل
نعم ليال ربما الان نشهد هدوءا حذرا في
عدد من المناطق التي كانت تجري فيها
الاشتباكات منذ صباح اليوم خاصه وسط
العاصمه الخرطوم وعدد من المناطق في مدينه
بحري وحتى على مستوى مدينه ام درمان الان
هنالك هدوءا نسبيا في هذه المناطق يعم
المكان لم نستمع لاصوات الرصاص ولا
المضادات الارضيه ولا حتى التحليق الطيران
ربما هذا الوقت يكون هنالك مجالا لاخذ
نوعا من الراحه ومن ثم تعود من جديد
الاشتباكات ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه ربما يعني
اكثر من ساعه لم تكن هنالك اشتباكات ولم
نرصد او نتابع حتى نشاهد عمليات اشتباك في
وسط العاصمه الخرطوم او المنطقه المحيطه
بقياده الجيش او مطار الخرطوم او حتى وسط
القصر الرئاسي وما كانت فيها من اشتباكات
قبل الساعه من الان هذا هو الوضع الان
الوضع الميداني يشير الى هدوء في عدد من
المناطق بشكل كبير وربما استطاع عدد من
المواطنين التحرك في هذه اللحظات لقضاء
عدد من الحاجيات الاساسيه والضروريه خاصه
وان النهار كانت فيه عدد من الاشتباكات
ربما صعبت من عمليه الحركه للتزود بعدد من
الاطعمه والاغذيه من الاماكن التي
يستطيعون الذهاب اليها
عمار يعني نحن نتحدث عن هدنه كما الهدى
السابقه هي متقطعه ولكن اليوم هناك يعني
حده الاشتباكات زادت بالساعات الماضيه
بحسب ضيوفنا بالفترات السابقه يقولون بان
الاشتباكات تنحصر الان في نقاط معينه ما
هي هذه النقاط وكيف تبدلت يعني الخريطه
على الارض
نعم الخريطه لم تتبدل كثيرا يعني محيط
القصر الرئاسي يشهد اشتباكات منذ اليوم
الاول وكذلك مطار الخرطوم هو المنطقه
المحيطه بقياده الجيش ربما كانت هنالك
مناطق جديده دخلت الى الصراع خاصه سلاح
الاشاره في مدينه بحري وهذه المنطقه تشكل
بعدا استراتيجيا لقياده الجيش وحتى لقوات
الدعم السريع باعتبار انها تبسط عدد كبير
من قواتها في تلك المنطقه منطقه مدينه
بحري وان هذا المكان المطل على النيل
والمطل من الجانب الشمالي الى الجانب
الجنوبي على قياده الجيش ما يعني لقوات
الدعم السريع في هذه المنطقه انها ربما
كانت تود ان تشكل طوقا امنيا وطوقا من
خلاله تستطيع ان تستهدف المكان الذي
تتواجد فيه قياده الجيش وبالجانب الاخر
امن الجيش هذا المكان وهذا ما يجعل الجيش
ربما من الاتجاه الشمالي في مامن النيران
لقوات الدعم السريعه التي تكون في تلك
المنطقه خاصه وان منطقه غرب بحري وهادئ
جنوب غرب بحري منطقه حله حمد والاملاك
تنتشر فيها عدد من قوات الدعم السريع
وفيها عدد من المدفعيه التي تقصف الاماكن
التي تتواجد في منطقه وسط العاصمه الخرطوم
هذه الرقعه لم تتسع كثيرا جدا في المنطقه
ولكن اثرت بشكل واضح وكبير على حياه الناس
من خلال ان الطيران الحربي ايضا كذلك
يتحرك في عدد من الارجاء في العاصمه ويؤثر
ذلك اذا ما كانت هنالك تحركات على الارض
لقوات الدعم السريع ما تجعل عمليه الحركه
داخل الشوارع صعبه جدا خاصه ان هنالك ايضا
عمليات تمشيط من القوات المسلحه في عدد
المناطق خاصه منطقه بحري وشرق النيل وهذا
يجعل عمليه الحركه او حتى الخروج في مثلها
كذا اوقات صعبا ما قد يعرضهم للرصاص
الطائش او يعرضهم لعدد من القذائف التي
ربما تتساقط في اي لحظه وهذا الوضع ايضا
هنالك عدد من الوفيات في عدد من المناطق
خاصه منطقه بري ومنطقه ام درمان شاهدنا ان
سقوط القضايا في العشوائيه اول مقذوفات
التي تطيش وتذهب الى تلك المناطق تسبب
بنسبه كبيره حاله من الذعر وحاله من
الاصابات وربما تؤدد للوفيات بحسب ما
تابعنا في كثير جدا من الاخبار التي نشرت
في تلك المناطق هذا الوضع يجعل عمليه
الحركه صعبا نوعا ما جعل الكثيرين يتحركون
ربما في هذه الاوقات قبل حلول الظلام ومع
الدقائق الاولى من حلول الظلام لقضاء عدد
من الحاجيات الاساسيه والضروريه شكرا لك
عمار على كل حال سنتابع معك كل التطورات
في النشرات اللاحقه شكرا لك عمار ابو شيبه
من الخرطوم
اما في اخر تطورات عمليه الاجلاء رصدت
كاميرا العربيه لحظات الاولى لوصول سفينه
الاجلاء الامريكيه الثانيه القادمه من
ميناء بورتسودان الى ميناء جده وعلى متنها
2122 شخصا من جنسيات مختلفه بينهم
امريكيون وصلت للتو الان السفينه
الامريكيه الى ميناء الجده الاسلامي وهي
تقف على رصيف رقم
77 وهي من ضمن السفن العسكريه الحربيه او
كذلك التجاريه الاجنبيه التي تقوم باجلاء
رعايه من جنسيات مختلفه ولعلها في مقدمه
هذه الجنسيات تحديدا على هذه السفينه هم
رعايا من امريكا وكذلك جنسيات اخرى طبعا
هذه السفينه هي هي ثاني سفن برونس ويك
الامريكيه العسكريه التي تقف على هذا
الرصيف تحديدا عدد الرعايه على هذه
السفينه تحديدا هم
222 من جنسيات مختلفه ولكن حتى الان لم
تصلنا من المسؤولين في السفاره الامريكيه
عدد الجنسيات تحديدا لهذه السفينه طبعا
هناك الجهات الامنيه والعسكريه في
السعوديه متواجده وكذلك الصحه التابعه
للسعوديه او وزاره الصحه السعوديه ايضا
تتواجد لم تردنا ايضا حتى الان افاده
كامله ووافيه من قبل السفاره الامريكيه
اذا ما كانت هناك اصابات سواء على متن هذه
السفينه او ايضا حالات طارئه صحيا
في السياقه للمتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الاثيوبيه انه تم تسهيل عبور ما لا يقل عن
4000 شخص من جنسيات مختلفه عبر المنافذ
الحدوديه مع السودان بالاضافه لاستقبال
اكثر من الف لاجئ سوداني
حتى الان تم تسهيل عبور اكثر من 4000 شخص
من 61 دوله عبر المنافذ الحدوديه مع
السودان وتم السماح ل 75 رحله جويه لعبور
الاجواء الاثيوبيه لاجلاء رعاياها من
السودان انطلاقا من مسؤولياتنا ما يحدث في
السودان سيكون له تاثير سلبي على اثيوبيا
من ميناء جده ينضم الينا مراسل عربيه
سلطان السلمي سلطان الصوره من هناك مع
يعني وصول على ما يبدو صافينا جديده من هم
ويعني الاعداد وكل التفاصيل لو سمحت
اهلا بك كما يظهر امامكم الان على الصوره
بشكل مباشر
بدء عمليات الانزال تبدا من كبار السن
وذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه ومن ثم بقيه
الركاب نتحدث ان هذه الرحله رقم سامي رقم
18 منذ بدا عمليه الاجلامي ميناء بورد
سودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه من
ضمنها خمسه عشر رحله عسكريه او سفينه
عسكريه هذه هي السفينه امانه وهي الرحله
الثالثه لهذه السفينه المدنيه التجاريه
السعوديه وعلامتها
1762 راكبا من ثلاثا 33 جنسيه نتحدث ايضا
من ضمنها او على متن هذه السفينه واحد
وثمانين امريكي ومواطن سعودي واحد فقط
ايضا يتحدثون الجنسيات تنوعت بين التشيك
وفرنسا وماليزيا والبرازيل وفانستان ومصر
والفلبين وبنغلاديش والدنمارك ونيجيريا
تعددت الجنسيات ايضا واعلنت وزاره
الخارجيه خلال الساعات الماضيه ان من تم
اجلائهم من السودان حتى هذه اللحظه قرابه
او تحديده 673 الشخص من 104 جنسيه من
ضمنهم فقط 246 مواطن سعودي وصلت قبل النصف
ساعه من الان ورست على الرصيف البحري رقم
سبعه كما نشاهد الان يبدا المرحله الاولى
بانزال ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه واصحاب
الحالات الطبيه الحرجه ومن ثم النساء
والاطفال وبعد ذلك بقيه الركاب الان بدل
هؤلاء العسكر بحمل الحقائب الخاصه بهاؤلاء
الرعايه ثم ايصالها الى الاسطول الحافلات
المخصص من قبل السلطات السعوديه حتى يتسنى
بشكل سريع انزال هؤلاء الرعايه في عمليه
سوف تستغرق قرابه الساعه واحده فقط ومن ثم
سوف يتم انهاء اجراءات دخولهم الاراضي
السعوديه في ظرف ساعه ونصف الساعه سوف يتم
منحهم تاشيره استثنائيه من قبل المديريه
العامه للجوازات لمده شهر واحد فقط ومن ثم
سوف ينتقلون عبر اسطول من الحافلات الى
مقرات السكن المخصصه لهم من قبل السلطات
السعوديه بعد التاكد من حالتهم الصحيه
وتلبيه كافه احتياجاتهم بحيث حيث يتواجد
طواقم الطبيه الخاصه بقاعده الملك فيصل
البحري للتعامل مع اي حاله حرجه فيما
يتعلق بكبار السن او من هم على مقاعد
متحركه هنالك مركبات خاصه تقوم بحملها
هؤلاء الرعايه وسوف ترافق اسطوره الحافلات
حتى يصل الى مقرات السكن سوف يكون في
استقبالهم عدد من الممثلين وزاره الخارجيه
السعوديه وعدد من القيادات الخاصه
بالقطاعات الامنيه المتواجده في قاعه
الملك فيصل البحريه وكذلك عدد من السفراء
والقناص الممثلي بلدان هؤلاء الرعايه
الاسهم 33 جنسيه تنوعت الجنسيات ونلاحظ
يوما بعد يوم تزداد عمليات الاجلاء
السعودي لهؤلاء الرعايه من ميناء بورت
سودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه او
حتى الى ميناء جده الاسلامي وكذلك الى
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه في جده اذا
تستقبل طوال اليوم رحلات جويه قادمه من
بورتسودان والى قات الملك عبد الله وايضا
تتم عمليه
الاسلام بدا من الخرطوم حيث توفر السفاره
السعوديه والسلطات السعوديه بالتنسيق مع
كافه الاطراف هنالك في السودان ممرات امنه
الى مدينه بورت سودان حيث تصل المسافه بين
الخرطوم وبين مدينه بورسودان قرابه 850
كيلو متر تقوم السلطات السعوديه بالتنسيق
مع كافه القطعه كافه الاطراف في السودان
على ممرات توفير ممرات امنه حتى يصلوا الى
بورت سودان ثم تقوم باستقبالهم اللجنه
اللجنه السعوديه المشكله او المشكله
لاستقبالها او لا الرعايه واخذ اوراق
السفر الخاصه بهم وجوازات السفر وتعبئه
الاستبيان الاستبيانات ومن ثم اعطاء
الاولويه لهؤلاء الرعايه للكبار السن وذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه الان نشاهد امامكم على
الكاميرا بشكل مباشر احدى السيدات كبار
السن على مقعد متحركه كما ذكرنا قبل قليل
الاولويه في النزول او في عمليات الانزال
تتم او تسحب او سوف تكون لهؤلاء الكبار
السن الان نشاهد في الصوره مباشره الضباط
والعسكر السعوديين يقومون بمساعده او
انزال هذه السيده حتى تتجه الى العربه
الخاصه بها برفقه كرسيها المتحرك ومن ثم
تبدا عمليه انزال لبقيه الركاب هذه هي
الرحله المدنيه الثالثه وسفينه امانه خاصه
السلطات السعوديه لنقل كافه الرعايه واكبر
عدد ممكن من الرعايه الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحري من نادي السفينه تستطيع استيعاب
اعداد اكبر اذ كانت اذا كانت الرحله
الاولى لهذه السفينه خلال ايام الماضيه
كان على متنها قرابه 1800 وكانت الرحله
الثانيه علمتني 1688 وهذه هي الرحله
الثالثه للسفينه امانه على متنها
1762 من الركاب من 33 جنسية وعلى متنها
فقط مواطن سعودي واحد فيما يتعلق بالساعات
القادمه المتوقعه وصول السفن تابعه
للبحريه السعوديه وكذلك على متنها عدد من
الرعايه لا تزال عمليات الاجلاء مستمره
منذ بدء النزاح النزاع المسلح بين قوات
الدعم السريع وبين الجيش السوداني تقوم
السلطات السعوديه باجلاء كافه الرعايه
المحتاجين هنالك من ميناء بورت سودان تاتي
على سبيل المثال تاتي هذه السفينه المدنيه
وسط حمايه وتامين من قوى من قبل قوات
البحريه بحرا وحتى كذلك جوا حتى تصل الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بسلام وامان ومن
ثم تبدا عمليه الانزال كما نشاهد دقائق
معدوده وسوف يتم انزال بقيه الركاب
بدايه بكبار السن وذول الاحتياجات الخاصه
وكذلك المحتاجين للرعايه الطبيه العاجله
اذ هنالك طواقم الطبيه في انتظار هؤلاء
الرعايه لاستقبالهم والتاكد من حالتهم
الصحيه ومن ثم يقومون بانزال الركاب هذه
السفينه سفينه امانه هي سفينه التجاريه
السعوديه قامت بتخصيص السلطات السعوديه
لنقل واجلاء اكبر عدد ممكن من هؤلاء
الرعايه منذ بدا عمليه اللجاء وهي الرحله
الثالثه لهذه السفينه امان التي حملت
بالفعل امانه الامانه ووصلتهم سالمين
غانمين علامه الى ارض السعوديه وتحديد الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بجده
فيما يتعلق بالخدمات المقدمه على متن هذه
السفينه فورا نعم
ساعود اليك طبعا خلال هذه التغطيه الى
قاعده الملك فيصل في جده شكرا لك على هذه
الرساله
من بورتسودان مشاهدي ينضم الينا موفد
العربيه محمد عثمان محمد يعني نتابع وصول
كل الذين يعني يتم اجلاءهم بالساعات
الماضيه الى جده كيف هي صوره من بورت
سودان ما هي الاعداد يعني التي يتم
تحضيرها لمغادره المرفا
اهلا بك ليال منذ ان وصلنا الى مدينه
بورسودان على ساحل البحر الاحمر حقيقه
وجدنا ان هذه المدينه تغيرت ملامحها تماما
وذلك نسبه لانها اصبحت مكتظه بالرعايه
الاجانب وكذلك ايضا بالسودانيين الراغبين
في مغادره البلاد بحرا عن طريق البحر
الاحمر وكذلك ايضا السودانيين الذين فروا
منا ولاه هذا هذه الحرب الدائره في
الخرطوم او في عدد ايضا من المدن السوداني
على اي حال تغيرت ملامح هذه المدينه التي
كانت هادئه واصبحت مكتظه بالكثير من من
الرعايه عدد من المشاهد والشواهد التي
رايناها
وانتبهنا اليها في هذه المدينه علي حال
يعني عمليات تفويج يعني الرعايه الاجانب
هي ما تزال مستمره حتى الان بلغت عدد
الرحلات عبر مطار بورسودان نحو 90 رحله
طيران غادرت من مطار بورتودان منذ بدايه
تفويج الرعايه الاجانب وكذلك العالقين
الاجانب وايضا عن طريق البحر هنالك اكثر
من 30 رحله بحريه غادرت مطار
الى ميناء بورسودان تحدث صراحه عن ان
هنالك يعني خطوات ايجابيه وهنالك انفراجه
كبيره في مساله نقل الرعايه اليمنيين وشكر
المملكه العربيه السعوديه على الجهود
وايضا على المجهودات التي تقوم بها
المملكه العربيه السعوديه في مساله اجلاء
الرعايه وكذلك هنالك خليه يعني نستطيع ان
نقول خليه عمل تقوم
اتتعلق بهذه العمليه المعقده اود ان اشير
هنا الى ان الاعياد الاعداد ربما تتزايد
بشكل كبير هنا في مدينه بورسودان على
اعتبار انه كلما تمددت رقعه النزاع المسلح
في مناطق عديده في السودان في الخرطوم او
حتى في المدن السودانيه هذا يؤشر الى
زياده عدد الاعداد التي ترغب في مغادره
البلاد وبالتالي تقع اعباء كبيره جدا على
السلطات هنا القائمه على امر التفويج
الرعايه الاجانب او حتى السودانيين
الراغبين في في مغادره السودان في هذه
الظروف الصعبه والصعبه جدا على اي حال
سنتابع معكم كل ما يستجد فيما يتعلق
بمساله التفويج ومساله نقل الرعايه
الاجانب والبعثات الدبلوماسيه لحظه بلحظه
كاميرا العربيه موجوده هنا وايضا سنحاول
ان نكون ايضا في ميناء سواكن هنا لك ايضا
رحلات تفويت تكون في ميناء سواكن سنتابع
لحظه بلحظه وكذلك ايضا من مطار بورسودان
محمد ساكمل معك من هناك الصوره يعني بما
انك وصلت وكنت منذ فتره يعني لم تزور هذه
المنطقه
بالخدمات الاساسيه الطرقات مع كل هذا
الازدحام الموجود هناك هل هي قادره البنى
التحتيه على استيعاب كل هذه الاعداد حتى
يعني الفنادق الاماكن التي يوضع فيها
الاشخاص او الجنسيات التي يتم اجلاءها من
الخرطوم الى بورتسودان ثم الى الوجهه
الاخرى بلادهم او الى جده وايضا الوجهه
الاخرى
من يريد الدخول الى يعني هذه المنطقه
الاجراءات الامنيه منعا هذا ما كنت ساسال
عنه موضوع الاجراءات الامنيه منعا
لاستغلال اي طرف ثالث او حتى اي يعني قوات
ممكن ان تكون تحضر لاي عمل لارهابي او
تفجير داخل هذه المنطقه محمد على كل حال
سنعود اليك لنقل الصوره من هناك ولكن اسمح
والمشاهدين ان انتقل منها التطورات
السودانيه مشاهدينا الى التطورات
الاوكرانيه بالتطورات الاوكرانيه الاداره
العسكريه لكيف تقول الان بان تم تفعيل
الدفاعات الجويه والتعامل مع اهداف بسماء
العاصمه وايضا هناك رصد لمسيرات في سماء
العاصمه
وسماع لذوي انفجارات في كييف اذا على ما
يبدو هناك تاهب امني داخل اكياف وهناك
انفجار في العاصمه الاوكرانيه وتفعيل حاله
الانذار الج اذا اعلان حاله الانذار
والتاهب الجوي في كييف طبعا هذا التغيير
الامني او التاهب الامني ياتي بعد الهجمه
على الكريم بعد الطائره المسيره التي ضربت
الكريم والتي قال بانها كانت تسعى الى
اغتيال او هي محاوله لاغتيال الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين وطبعا كان هناك
الكثير من التصريحات الرسميه الروسيه التي
قالت بان الرد سيكون بالزمان والمكان
المناسبين طبعا كيف نفد المسؤوليه عن هذه
الهجمات واعتبرت بان كل ما يحصل هو
سيناريو روسي
لجذب ولتكثيف الاستعطاف الداخلي بظل هذه
الحرب الدائره طبعا للروس وجهه نظر اخرى
هنا وسمعنا التصريحات التي تقول بان هذه
الهجمات هي بتشجيع امريكي وبايدي غربيه
نفذتها كياف على اوكرانيا على طبعا روسيا
[موسيقى]
كره ثلج الازمه الاوكرانيه تكبر يوما بعد
يوم حادث المسيرتين فوق قصر الكرملين صب
الزيت اكثر فوق نيران الحرب المشتعله اصلا
موسكو وبعد اتهامها بمحاوله اغتيال بوتين
صعدت اللهجه اكثر الخارجيه الروسيه توعدت
برد يكون بحجم التهديد سهام الانتقاد
الروسيه اتجهت مباشره نحو الولايات
المتحده فقرارات القيام بمثل هذه الاعمال
تتخذ في واشنطن وليس كيافا التي تنفذ يقول
الكرملين
مثل هذه القرارات وتعريف الاهداف وتعريف
الوسائل كل هذا تمليه واشنطن على
اوكرانيا نفت الاتهامات الروسيه جمله
وتفصيلا ووصفتها بالكاذبه فرسيا اختلقت
الهجوم لكونها تعلم انها خسرت الحرب
والكريم لان يستغل هذه الروايه لتحفيز
جنوده على الاستمرار في الحرب ومقدمه لعمل
عسكري شامل
اما زيلينس كيف حاول القيام بهجمه مرتده
من داخل مقر محكمه الجنايه الدوليه عبر
المطالبه بمحاكمه الرئيس الروسي
تجب معاقبه بوتين على افعاله هنا في عاصمه
القانون الدولي حليف اوكرانيا الاتحاد
الاوروبي دعا الى عدم استخدامه
ذريعه لتصعيد الحرب ويكو ندع روسيا الى
عدم استخدام هذا الهجوم المزعوم ذريعه
لمواصله هذا التصعيد للحرب اكبر داعم لكي
اف سياسيا وعسكريا الولايات المتحده ابدت
تشكيكها فيما يقع البيت الابيض قال انه
ينظر بعين الريبه لكل ما يصدر عن موسكو في
وقت اشارت الامم المتحده الى انه لا يمكن
تاكيد المعلومات الروسيه عن هجوم اوكراني
على الكرملين بلال الوجداني العربيه
معنى الصحافه محمد البابا محمد بدايه هل
نتحدث عن طائرات مسيره او عن صواريخ او عن
ماذا لانه طبعا طريقه التعامل تختلف تماما
نعم بالفعل يعني قبل حوالي عشره او 15
دقيقه سمعت اصوات انفجارات ويعني حتى هذه
اللحظه نسمع اصوات اطلاق نار ورايت يعني
على بعد حوالي ثلاثه واربع كيلو مترات كان
هناك مسيره من نوع اورلان كانت تطهير فوق
العاصمه الاوكرانيه وكانت تحاول الدفاعات
الجويه استهدافها وسمعنا اطلاق الدفاعات
الجويه صواريخ من الدفاعات الجويه وصوت
انفجار بعد استهداف او انزال او ضرب هذه
المسيره ايضا يعني بين الحين والاخر نسمع
صوت اطلاق نار فوق العاصمه الاوكرانيه
انتهى الانذار الجوي في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف بعض اسقاط المسيره التي
كانت تحوم وتطير فوق العاصمه الاوكرانيه
يعني رايت على شاشه الهاتف انتهاء الانذار
الجوي في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف يعني على
مدى حوالي 20 دقيقه كنا نسمع اصوات
انفجارات في
كييف ونسمع صوت اطلاق نار ورشاشات كانت
تستهدف الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
الاوكرانيه مسيره كانت تطير فوق العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف محمد النقطه التي كانت
تطير فوقها بما اننا نتحدث عن استهداف
للكريم لان هل كانت فوق
قبل ان اخذ منك انتقل الى البيت الابيض
مشاهدينا وكلمه
في قصف مدن اوكرانيه بصوره مستمره وما
قمنا به هو اننا قمنا
كغالبيه
من خلال ادراكنا لما قام باطلاقه من
مجموعه كبيره من هذه الصواريخ التي طالت
مدن اوكرانيا كثيره وبعد ذلك استطاعت
الدفاعات الجويه ان تتصدى لها ونحن وزننا
نركز على هذا الامر قلتم ان الولايات
المتحده
سوف تقوم بتعزيز قدراتي اوكرانيا الدفاعيه
وقد يكون هناك مساعده قادمه في خلال اسبوع
القادمه
متى تتوقعون ان يتم تعزيز هذه المساعدات
المقبله اننا
سوف نفعل كل ما بوسنا ليس فقط هنا في
الولايات المتحده بل نتحدث ايضا
بان كافه شركائنا
سوف يكونوا جاهزين استطيع ان اجيب وان
اقول باننا سوف نفعل كلنا لتاكد من جاهزيه
اوكرانيا وانه سوف يكون لديهم كل وجل ما
يطلب في سياق العمليات الدفاعيه وتكمل
سواء من قبل الدفاع او المشاهد او
الذخيره فضلا عن التدريب
الذي قد يطالوا عشرات الكتائب من القوات
الاوكرانيه وحول كيفيه استخدام الاسلحه
المختلفه وهذا
حسب اعتقادهم يرونه انها المساله التي هم
بها الحاجه اليها في في استخدام
اسلحه الدفاع
اسلحه اسلحه المدفعيه في ميدان المعركه
وسوف سوف نرى استمرانا في الدعم من قبل
الولايات المتحده مع اما فيما يتعلقوا في
كيفيه التنفيذ مساله العمليه المضاده
العمليه الهجوميه المضاده فهي متروكه
لاوكرانيا
فيما يتعلق بالهجوم الذي تم بشرنه على
الكرمل هل كان لديكم قدره التحقق من اي
اشرطه فيديو مصوره حول ما حدث للوقوف على
تفاصيل تلك الحادثه وحول النظريات
المختلفه التي تم طرحها حول ما حدث اخر ما
قد اقوم به هو التكهن
ولكننا نحن نفعل
بكل ما نستطيع من اجل نتفهم ما الذي يحدث
لذا
لن اتكهنت كما قلت فيما يتعلق بالصين
السفير
السفير الصيني
لدى الولايات المتحده قال بانهم مستعدون
للخراطي في مستوى
اذا نكتفي مشاهدينا بهذا القدم من رد
البيت الابيض اذا هذه الصور من استهداف
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كما نشاهد المسيره
بهذا الفيديو
والتي قامت الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
باسقاط
اذا
مشاهدينا هذا الفيديو الذي يوثق الطائره
المسيره التي استهدفت العاصمه قبل قليل
وهي طبعا تاتي بعد الاستهداف استهداف
الكريم الذي يقول عنه الاكرم بانه استهداف
امريكي بايادي اوكرانيه ومحاوله اغتيال
وزعزع للاستقرار الداخلي الروسي طبعا طيله
هذا النهار كانت هناك صفارات انذار
وانذارات جويه بالعاصمه اكياف وهناك حاله
من التاهب العسكري بظل التصريحات الروسيه
التي قالت بانها سترد بالزمان والمكان
المناسبين على هذه المحاوله التي اعتبرتها
محاوله ارهابيه لنظام ترهيبي كما تصفه
طبعا موسكو
للمزيد من التفاصيل من هناك من العاصمه
كيف ينضم الينا حذيفه عادل لمراسل العربيه
حذيفه هل من تفاصيل اضافيه حول عمليه
الاستهداف هذه الطائره المسيره هل استهدفت
المنطقه التي يقع فيها المقر الحكوميه ام
اماكن سكن عاديه
مساء الخير يعني حتى الان المعلومات صحيحه
حول هذا الامر الطائره تم
ضربها يعني في منطقه بعيده بعض الشيء عن
مركز المدينه مكان
مراكز صنع القرار ولكن حتى الان لا يوجد
معلومات حول الامر اذا مكان هنالك اي
ضحايا او ان كان ان بعض الشظايا سقطت
واصابه اي جسم او شخص او بعض المصابين حتى
الان المعلومات حول هذا الامر طبعا اعلنت
هيئه الاركان العامه الاوكرانيه عن 66
ضربه جويه نفذتها القوات الروسيه كذلك
اعلنت عن سته ضربات صاروخيه استهدفت
كراماتورس واستهزفت
وكذلك 33 ضربه براجمات الصواريخ هذا خلال
الساعات فقط الماضيه يعني منذ اخر مباشر
كنا نتحدث قبل حوالي ثلاثه ساعات كل هذا
نفذ في جبهه القتال وكذلك قالت انها خلال
يعني اليوم منذ الصباح وحتى الان استطعت
ان تصب خمسين هجوما في مناطق متفرقه طبعا
يتركز القتال في مخمود
مارينكا هذه المناطق التي يتركز فيها
القتال وكذلك يعني على الصعيد تعلمين ان
الرئيس
حذيفه قبل ان انتقل الى الشق السياسي هذه
المناطق اصلا فيها صراع وفيها هجمات وفيها
يعني بالحالات العاديه لكن العاصمه تهدا
ثم تعود موضوع الاستهدافات الى هناك الان
بعد هذه المسيره هل هناك حاله تاهب امني
ما الذي يحصل هل يعني هناك حركه عاديه ما
زالت موجوده للسكان ام هناك خوف حقيقي من
طلعات جويه هذه الليله وبالليالي اللاحقه
نعم يعني قبل قليل كنت اقف قرب الملجع
طبعا تم الغاء حاله التاهب الجوي قبل
حوالي دقيقتين او ثلاث دقائق ونحن نستعد
لهذا المباشر قبل خمس دقائق فقط كنت اقف
بالقرب من مبنى سكني ضخم جدا فيه عدد كبير
جدا من الشقق السكنيه لم ينزل احد من هذا
من هذه المبنى للاختباء في الملجا على
الرغم من الصافات الانذار حاله التاهب
الجوي وجدت فقط سيده ومعها ثلاثه اطفال
يعني ايضا اسره تتكون من شخصين يعني من
هذا المنزل الذي قد يكون يسكن فيه ما يزيد
عن الالف اسره وهذا الوقت المواطنين عادوا
الى منازلهم يعني ونلاحظ ايضا من الاضواء
المضاده ان جميع تقريبا جميع الشقق فيها
اشخاص لكنهم لم ينزلوا وهذا يؤكد ان
المواطنين ما زالوا لا يابهون بحالات
التاهب الجوي في العاصمه كيف ولكن عن
الصعيد الرسمي طبعا ايضا لابد ان نشير الى
انه تم الاعلان عن ان في الاسبوع القادم
وهذا الاعلان صدر من سفير اوكرانيا في
اسرائيل الذي قال انه يتوقع في الاسبوع
القادم ان تنشر انظمه انظمه مضاده
للصواريخ عفوا انظمه الرادار كاشفه
لصواريخ اسرائيليه تستطيع ان تكشف اي جسم
واي صاروخ مهما كانت طبيعته او نوعه
وتستطيع ان ترصده ان تحدد المنطقه
بالتحديد التي يمكن ان يسقط فيها هذا
الصاروخ او الجسم او الطائره المسيره ايا
كان الجسم الذي يتحرك تجاه العاصمه كيف
يمكن لهذه الانظمه انظمه الرادار ان ترصده
بل وتحدد مكان السقوط والحي والمنطقه
والقطر الذي يمكن ان يحدث فيه الضرر وهذا
سيساعد العاصمه كثيرا من تجنب الضربات
الصاروخيه وطبعا بالمقابل بعض الرصد يمكن
لانظمه الدفاع الجوي ان تستهدف هذه
الاجسام هذا من الامور المهمه التي لابد
ان يشير اليها في الاسبوع القادم نتوقع ان
تنشر هذه انظمه الرادار في العاصمه لحمايه
العاصمه كيب خاصه ان هنالك توقع في التاسع
مما او بعد التاسع من ما يمكن ان يكون
هنالك استهداف واسع النطاق تحديدا للعاصمه
كيف
حذيفه طبعا ساعود اليك خلال هذه التغطيه
شكرا لك الان مشاهدينا ايضا منضم الينا
الصحافه محمد البابا محمد يعني سمعنا
رساله حذيفه وان هناك توقعات او تاكيد
لنشر منظومات الدفاع الجويه بظل كل
التهديدات الروسيه بالرد على ما اسمته
بالطلعات الارهابيه الاوكرانيه
بالمنحه الاخر السكان داخل كييف هل
يتحضرون الى هذا السيناريو اتحدث عن
سيناريو التصعيد بعد التاسع من هذا الشهر
يعني بعد ما حصل بالامس وما حصل خاصه في
الكريم الاستهداف هناك ترقب من شارع
الاوكراني وراي العام الاوكراني حول كيفيه
الرد كيفيه الرد كيف سترد روسيا ونوعيه
الهجمات التي ستقوم بها ولكن يعني نحن
خلال الايام هل يشجع اليوم الشارع
الاوكراني على الذهاب الى هكذا نوع من
المواجهه مع الكريم يعني الذهاب الى داخل
الكرملين
الجميع يعني انا ساشرح الراي العام
الاوكراني في هذه الايام معظم الاوكرانيون
يدعمون الجيش الاوكراني ويرفضون اي تشبيك
بقرارات الاداره الاوكرانيه الاداره
العسكريه او حتى الرئيس الاوكراني ويعلمون
تماما ان ما حصل في الكرملين هي مجرد
مسرحيه وهذا ما يتداول عبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي عبر وسائل الاعلام الاعلاميين
الاوكرانيين الصحفيين الاوكرانيين يتحدثون
ان هذه المحاوله من روسيا لاولا لتشويه
الهجوم المضاد الذي الذي ستقوم به
اوكرانيا في يعني خلال الايام القليله
المقبله وايضا لتحميل اوكرانيا مسؤوليه اي
هجوم او رد ستكون به روسيا خاصه ان الجميع
يعني بالامس كان هناك حديث انه ربما سيكون
هناك رد نووي على اوكرانيا بدا بدات يعني
بدا السكان يتداولون انهم بحاجه الى ماده
اليود الى الى كمامات يعني واقي من النووي
هذا المكان يتداول عبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي خوفا ان تقوم روسيا بتصعيد كبير
بالذهاب الى الملاشي او يعني التزام
بالحذر النشوي يعني سيكون هناك خطر على
المدنيين تعمل يعني البلديه يعني وزاره
الداخليه والشرطه يعملون بشكل كبير وهناك
حملات عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وعبر
القنوات وسائل الاعلام الاوكرانيه لحسس
السكان خاصه في هذه الفتره ولا ننسى
بالامس من السفاره
جميع المواطنين الامريكيين بالالتزام فورا
من هذا المنطلق هل هناك يعني تشديد
بالاجراءات الامنيه داخل العاصمه خصوصا ان
هناك خوف ان يتم عمليه تفجير من الداخل
ليس فقط من الجو
يعني الامن في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
ممسوك بدرجه كبيره هناك حرفيه من
المخابرات من الجيش الاوكراني استخبارات
العسكريه والشرطه دائما يعني خلال فتره
شهرين او ثلاثه اشهر خفت عمليه قبض على
جواسيس الذين وكما يتداول معظمهم غادر
العاصمه الاوكرانيه لان الامن فعلا ممسوك
بشكل كبير حتى الجرائم العاديه الصغيره
تتعامل معها الشرطه الاوكرانيه بكل حزم
وكل جديه يعني الوضع فيه وانا عندما اتيت
الى العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف تفاجات من
الوضع الامني الممسوك بشكل كبير مثلا يعني
قبل حوالي شهرين في المنطقه التي اعيش بها
تم القاء القبض على جندي روسي تخفى واختبا
في احد المنازل لمده اربعه اشهر ويعني
بالتعاون بين السكان والشرطه المحليه تم
فورا القاء القبض عليه وهو الان يعني
الاوكرانيه وايضا ولكن انا اريد هناك سؤال
يعني سالتيه لحسيفه اين كانت تطير انا كنت
في المنطقه
من المنطقه التي تطير بهيا من الجهه
الجنوبيه يعني الجنوبيه الشرقيه للعاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف وبعيده الى حد ما عن الحي
الحكومي كانت تطير وقامت هذه المسيره
بدوران دائري لثلاثه مرات قبل ان يتم
استهدافها بصاروخ اطلق من الدفاعات الجويه
محمد هل لديك اي معطيات عن مواقع
الانفجارات يعني كان حذيفه قد افدنا بانها
بضواحي العاصمه هل لديك اي تفاصيل اخرى
اين سقطت هل هناك اكثر من مسيره او نتحدث
فقط عن مسيره واحده حتى هذه اللحظه يعني
لم يعلن عن ان كان هناك سيارات اخرى ولكن
معظم اصوات الانفجارات كانت من خلال
الدفاعات الجويه التي عندما تطلق تنفجر
فيها في الهواء وتسبب اصوات انفجارات وهي
ليس الاستهداف مسيرات الى اهداف يعني
عسكريه او اهداف مدنيه معظم ما نسمعه هي
اصوات الدفاعات الجويه الصواريخ يعني
صواريخ انس التي تستهدف المسيرات في حال
لم تصب المسيره تنفجر في الهواء وتسبب
يعني صوت انفجار كبير او عندما تصطدم
بهدفها بالمسيرات ايضا يعني تطلق اصوات
انفجارات عنيفه جدا شكرا لك محمد البابا
حدثتنا منك
[موسيقى]
اعلنت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه ان الهجوم
على الكريملم باستخدام المسيرات حادث غريب
وغامض ولا يزال بحاجه الى تفسير حيث قالت
بانه ليس لديها اي معلومات محدده حول هذا
الموضوع ولا يمكنها مناقشه الروايات
المتعلقه به
بدورها اعتبرت الخارجيه الايطاليه ان اي
عمل عسكري بما فيه محاولات استهداف مبنى
الكريم في روسيا اعتبرته امرا لا يخدم
التسويه السلميه في اوكرانيا وقالت
الخارجيه الايطاليه ان جميع الهجمات التي
تسببت بالضرر على مبنى الكريملان لا يعرف
تفاصيلها لحد اللحظه وانها لا تخدم السلام
الذي يجب ان يكون في مصلحه اوكرانيا والذي
سينتج عنه استقلال اوكرانيا على حد قوله
اكد رئيس الوزراء الهولندي على ان بلاده
تعمل مع الشركاء لدراسه خيارات مختلفه
لتوريد مقاتلات اف 16 لاوكرانيا ونوه في
مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع رئيس الوزراء
البلجيكي في لهاي عن عدم وجود اي محرمات
في هذا الامر مشيرا الى ان بلاده تدرس
مختلف الخيارات مع شركائها مثل بلجيكا
والدنمارك حول توريد هذه المقاتلات
لاوكرانيا
فتحت شرطه برلين تحقيقا في تسريب على اثر
قيام احد عناصرها بتسريب نبا زياره الرئيس
الاوكراني لالمانيا الى وسائل الاعلام
واكدت الشرطه فتحه تحقيق بشبهه خيانه
اسرار بعد قيام صحيفه بنشر انباء عن
استعداد لزياره زيلينسكي المقرره في
الثالث عشر من مايو الحاليه وتضمينها
تفاصيل ومحطه الزياره قاعده الشرطه وجهت
انتقادات لاذعه للمصدر مضيفه ان قيام فرد
واحد بتشويه سمعه شرطه برلين بطريقه مخزيه
امر لا يحتمل
مشاهدينا بالعوده الى موضوع الاستهداف
استهداف العاصمه كياف هذه صور جديده
لعمليه الاستهداف والتي كما تابعنا قبل
قليل تم التصدي لها وهي طائره مسيره من
قبل الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
كما افدنا الزملاء هناك هذا اسقطت هذه
المسجره بضواحي العاصمه ولم تدخل يعني
الوسط العاصمه حيث المقر الحكوميه وحيث
المقر الرئاسيه ايضا
اذا هذا الاستهداف ياتي وسط انباء عن
وتحذيرات روسيه وايضا انباء من اوكرانيا
بان عمليه ورقعه الاستهداف الروسيه
لاوكرانيا ستزداد وبانها تاتي للانقضاض
على ما يعرف بالعمليه المضاده التي
ستطلقها اوكرانيا كان من المفترض ان تبدا
الاسبوع المقبل بحسب كل التقديرات اتى هذا
الرد الروسي على الاستهداف للكرامل
والتصعيد حتى قبل ما تبدا عمليه يعني
المضاده عام العمليه المضاده التي كان من
المقرر ان تبداها القوات الاوكرانيه
لاستعاده الاراضي التي اخذتها روسيا والتي
يعني هي الان تخضع لي السلطات الروسيه
اكدت الناطقه باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه
ضروره ابقاء قنوات الاتصال مع روسيا
مفتوحه نافيه توفر اي شروط للتفاوض في هذه
المرحله
موقفنا ثابت وهو ان المحافظه على قنوات
مفتوحه مع روسيا امر مهم ولا غنى عنه في
حال اردنا الدخول في مفاوضات ولكن للاسف
في هذه المرحله شروط التفاوض ليست متوفره
على الارض واعتقد ان تصعيد الضربات ضد
البنى التحتيه المدنيه في اوكرانيا يظهر
تمسك موسكو باهدافها الى حد كبير فضلا عن
التصريحات التصعيديه للسيدف هذا الصباح
دعا الرئيس الاوكراني
الى انشاء محكمه خاصه لمحاكمه روسيا على
غزوها بلاده مطالبا بتحقيق عداله واسعه
النطاق عبر القانون رافضا فكره الافلات
الهجين من العقاء زينسكي اكد ايضا ان
روسيا يجب ان تتحمل المسؤوليه كامله في
حربها في اوكرانيا
في الوقت الذي لم ترجح فيه المسيرات كفت
روسيا في الحرب الا انها اسهمت في تماسك
الجيش الاوكراني وبعثرت تحصينات ثاني اقوى
جيش في العالم التفاصيل في التقرير
التاليه
نجمه الصمود الاوكراني كما وصفت دعمت عمود
المساعدات الغربيه العسكري وصنعت الفارقه
في الحرب لا سيما ان استخدامها جاء من
الطرفين لتحديد مواقع العدو وتوجيه نيران
المدفعيه نحوها
على اعتاب كييف كانت المسيرات الاوكرانيه
اول من اقفل الباب بوجه القوات الروسيه
لتسحب ذيولها خلال ساعات وتتفرق شرقا
وجنوبا فيما الخاصره اي شبه جزيره القرم
التي زرعت الشوكه الروسيه فيها منذ تسع
سنوات تتعرض كل حين لهجمات بالمسيرات
هدفها الاولي قطع امداد المعدات والغذاء
عن موسكو واستهداف اسطول البحر الاسود
الروسي في سيفا ستوبول
جيش الدرون الاوكراني الذي قلل من اضرار
التفوق الروسي حجما وقدره شمل بدايه
مسيرات تجاريه رخيصه الثمن الصينيه الصنع
دي جي اي مافيكا حضرت صادراتها بكين لاحقا
على اعتبار انها للاستخدام المدني فقط لكن
مسيرات بيرقدار التركيه شكلت العين
الاساسيه على اوكار الخصومه تحمل كاميرات
استطلاعيه ويمكن تسليحها بقنابل موجهه
بالليزر واستخدمت بالهجوم الذي اغرق سفينه
موسكفا الروسيه في ابريل 2022 لكن هذه
المسيرات يعيبها حجمها الكبير وبطء حركتها
وسهوله اسقاطها مقارنه بكمكاز الانتحاريه
فالعصافير القاتله او الذخيره المتسكعه
تتميز بقدرتها على التحليق في منطقه الهدف
المحدد مسبقا وتضرب عند التعرف الى العدو
تطلق من مسافات بعيده ويصعب اكتشافها لصغر
حجمها اهميه هذا السلاح ادركته موسكو
سريعا فاندفعت الى ايران لشراء مسيرات
انتحاريه عمياء بدقه ضعيفه استخدمتها لاول
مره في خركيف ثم كييف واوداسا وميكولياف
غير ان هذه المسيرات لم ترقى لتوقعات
الروس واخفقت كثيرا وفق واشنطن
مشاهدينا سانتقل الى هذه الصور التي
وصلتنا قبل قليل عن اسقاط الطائره المسيره
في كييف اذا كما نشاهد بهذه الصور هذه
الطائره كانت بمحيط القصر الرئاسي وتم
اسقاط هناك يعني خلافا لما افدنا به زملاء
من هناك بانها بمحيط العاصمه او بالاطراف
اذا هي بمحيط القصر الرئاسي وهي طبعا رد
مباشر من قبل الكريم على الاستهداف الذي
طال الكريمه اذا طائره مسيره على الكرملين
بطائره مسيره على القصر الرئاسي باوكرانيا
بهذه النقطه بالذات هناك يعني يعني وجود
للقصر الرئاسي قصر الحكومي وايضا مجلس
النواب وبالتالي هي دخلت الى العمق
الاوكراني لتقول بان اي استهداف للكرملين
سيقابل استهداف للمقر الحكوميه والرئاسيه
لكاف
هنا عند هذا التمثال الذي نشاهده مشاهدينا
هي نقطه الساحه او الوسط الاساسي داخل
العاصمه وراء هذا التمثال هناك القصر
الرئاسي هناك
المقر الحكوميه اي مجلس الوزراء وكل
الوزارات الاخرى وهناك ايضا بالجانب الاخر
المقر مجلس النواب
قالت الصين ان هناك حاجه الى اليقظه
الشديده لمواجهه توسع الناتو شرقا في
منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ وجاء هذا بعد
ورود تقارير تفيد بان حلف شمال الاطلسي
يخطط لانشاء مكاتب في اليابان لتسهيل
المشاورات مع الحلفاء والشركاء الامنيين
في المنطقه اذا ما زلنا نتابع هذه الصور
لعمليه اسقاط الطائره المسجره الروسيه في
سماء العاصمه كياف وتحديدا فوق القصر
الرئاسي الاوكراني
[تصفيق]
مشاهدينا
نعم مشاهدينا ساكمل او سانهي هذه الساعه
لكن تغطيه العربيه لاحداث السودان والان
احداث اوكرانيا مستمره والان مع الزميله
ميسون
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات